Cheers.
Die Jungs im Club werden staunen. Na die im Chaos Computer Club, die machen immer nur Pille-Palle. Börsengeschäfte zu manipulieren, davon träumen die ablos. Jürgen, du kannst doch deinen Leuten aus diesem Börsenclub nicht erzählen, was wir gemacht haben. Natürlich, wieso denn nicht?
Na, weil das geheim bleiben muss, was spinnst du?
Ach, jetzt macht man mal was Spannendes und dann...
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express. Nach langer Zeit mal wieder dem Sarg entstiegen. Eine lange Pause seit der letzten Sendung. Das hat viele Gründe, auf die ich jetzt hier aber nicht eingehen möchte. Tatsache ist, wir sind wieder da. Und das Thema der Ausgabe Nummer 39 von Chaosradio Express ist der Nedap-Pack, die technische Auseinandersetzung mit den Wahlcomputern aus Holland. Und dazu ist Frank mit dabei. Und wir werden uns das gleich mal anschauen. Tschüss Ja, willkommen bei Chaosradio Express und ich sag erst mal Hallo Frank. Ist es dir jetzt laut genug?
Leise genug.
Leise genug, laut genug. Wir haben hier noch ein paar kleine technische Detail-Einstellungsprobleme, aber das gehört ja dazu zu Chaosradio. Ich versuch das jetzt in Chaosradio Express auch perfekt nachzuöffen. So und ja, wir sind hier versammelt zu unserem Dauerthema der letzten Wochen und Monate und wie es aussieht, wird uns das auch noch eine ganze Weile lang beschäftigen. Macht nämlich auch echt Spaß. Nämlich Wahlcomputer. Vielleicht habt ihr schon davon gehört. Uns würde es fast überraschen, wenn nicht. Denn es sind ja eine ganze Menge Veröffentlichungen dazu durchs Netz gegangen. Und mittlerweile erreicht es auch so die traditionelleren Medien, was gut ist. Da ist auf jeden Fall auch noch eine ganze Menge Aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten. Und wir möchten jetzt mal einen bestimmten Aspekt beleuchten, der in den letzten Monaten noch mal zu einer extremen Belebung der Diskussion geführt hat, nämlich der Hack der Wahlcomputersysteme, wie sie in Holland eingesetzt werden, die Wahlcomputer der Firma Nedap.
Genau, Nedap steht für niederländischer Apparattebau. Das ist eine Firma, die eigentlich ursprünglich primär mit Spielautomaten und ähnlichen Dingen zu tun hatte und Warenausgabeautomaten, die dann irgendwann angefangen hat, Wahlcomputer zu bauen, die von der technischen Ausstattung her sich nicht sehr wesentlich von einem Warenausgabeautomaten unterscheiden. Im Kern steckt da halt so ein Motorola 68000 drin. Das heißt, ein Prozessor, den wir zuletzt in freier Wildbahn in größerer Stückzahl so zu Zeiten vom Atari ST und vom Amiga 500 gesehen haben. Das heißt also dann doch ziemlich antiquiertes Zeug. Die Komplexität dieser Wahlcomputer ist, naja, eigentlich weniger als ein Atari ST, muss man sagen. Also sie haben halt unglaublich wenig Speicher, 16 Kilobyte nämlich. Und die Software steckt da drin auch nicht auf irgendeinem modernen Speicher, sondern auf so einem richtigen oldschool EEPROM.
Also bevor wir da zu tief in die Technik einsteigen, wollte ich noch mal kurz erläutern, wie es überhaupt dazu gekommen ist. Also die Situation in Holland ist ja die, dass dort schon seit einiger Zeit Wahlcomputer zum Einsatz kommen.
Flächendeckend ja. Also Holland wählt nahezu komplett mit Wahlcomputern.
Und das auch nahezu komplett mit den Computern der Firma Nedap? Die nehmen da wie viel Prozent des Marktes ein?
Das sind wohl so um die 90 Prozent. Und der Rest war eben bis heute SDU-Wahlcomputer. Also das ist noch Wahlcomputer von einer anderen Firma, die noch ein viel bizarreres Geschäftsmodell hat als Nedap. Also die Firma SDU hat so Full-Service-Wahlen angeboten. Das heißt, sie sind hingegangen und haben gesagt, pass auf, ihr müsst euch da nicht drum kümmern. Wenn Wahltag ist, dann kann du euch diese Wahlcomputer in die Wahllokale fertig konfiguriert und abends bekommt ihr dann das Ergebnis durchtelefoniert. Und dazwischen habt ihr dann nichts mehr damit zu tun.
Das ist so ein ehemaliger Staatsbetrieb?
Genau, das ist sozusagen so die Bundesdruckerei von Niederlanden ungefähr.
Die auch mal privatisiert wurde vor einiger Zeit?
Genau, die haben halt in diesen SDU-Wahlcomputern etwas moderne Technologie. Wir haben die noch nicht in den Fingern gehabt, im Gegensatz zu den Nedap-Dingern. Da steckt halt wohl ein PC drin, so richtig, so ein PC mit so einem normalen Windows drauf. Und wohl ein Modem oder gar ein GPRS-Modem, über das dann die Ergebnisse verteilt werden. Was natürlich dazu führt, dass es eine unglaubliche Menge von Angriffsvektoren gibt. Und gerade heute hat ja der zuständige Minister in den Niederlanden...
Genau, wir haben heute Montag, den 30. Oktober 2006, und das ist heute die große Nachricht eingeschlagen.
Genau, 14 Uhr hat der zuständige Minister verkündet, dass SDU-Wahlcomputer nicht mehr zugelassen sind in den Niederlanden, d.h. dass keine Wahlen damit mehr durchgeführt werden dürfen. Hintergrund war wohl, dass sie mal den holländischen Geheimdienst, die AIWD, gebeten haben, sich die SDU-Wahlcomputer mal anzugucken. Und die haben dann wohl im Wesentlichen die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen und die Notbremse gezogen. Und daraufhin wurden dann halt heute die SDU-Wahlcomputer von ihrer Zulassung befreit.
Also das ist ja im Prinzip jetzt der vorläufige Höhepunkt der Kampagne und die Kampagne müssen wir natürlich an dieser Stelle auch mal erwägen. Wir vertrauen Wahlcomputers, Stammcomputers. Das haben wir fünfmal geübt. Wir können es eh nicht. Wir vertrauen Wahlcomputern nicht auf Holländisch. Heißt die Projektgruppe rund um Rob Congreib, der ja auch bekannt ist als Gründer von Access for All. Er ist lange Mitglied unserer europäischen Hacker-Szene und auch mit uns verbunden. Von daher hat sich auch gleich diese Kooperation aufgezwungen, dass hier Leute vom CCC die ganze Sache mitmachen.
Es fing halt so an, dass Rob und ein paar andere Holländer auf den Trichter kamen, dass das mit diesen Wahlcomputern eigentlich so nicht mehr geht.
Er musste mal wählen und musste auf diesen New-Vote, wie die Maschinen auch bezeichnenderweise heißen, das ist so ähnlich wie New-Speak, und er wollte das nicht.
Genau, also am Ende war halt klar, das geht halt nicht mehr. Und hat dann halt angefangen, eine Kampagne zu planen. Wir haben halt ein paar öffentliche Statements gemacht, wo halt gesagt wurde, Wahlcomputer sind da nicht vertrauenswürdig, weil man sie halt nicht nachprüfen kann, weil man die Stimmen nicht nachzählen kann und weil es ohnehin halt eine Technologie ist, die halt nie unter Sicherheitsaspekten evaluiert wurde.
Ich meine, für uns als, ich sag mal, einen ganz großen Anführungsstrichen Experten oder zumindest sagen wir mal als Leuten, die wir irgendwie schon immer mit Computern gearbeitet haben, für uns ist das so selbstverständlich, dass so eine Maschine keinerlei Vertrauensbasis sein kann.
Die stürz halt dauernd ab, um mal gar damit etwas anzufangen.
Die stürz ab und es gibt irgendwie so viele Orte, wo man was drehen kann und eigentlich ist man sein Leben lang damit beschäftigt, diese Unendlichkeit der Möglichkeiten auszuspielen. Das ist ja bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt auch immer ein großer Spaß. Gerade wenn es darum geht, neue Projekte zu machen, überlegt man sich immer wieder, welche dieser unendlichen Möglichkeiten kann ich jetzt zum Einsatz bringen, wo passt es wirklich? Bloß in dem Moment, wo man einen Vertrauensbereich definieren möchte, kommen einem natürlich diese ganzen tausend Türen, durch die man gehen kann, vollkommen in die Quere, weil dort eben andere Leute auch durchgehen können.
Man kann halt im Prinzip keinen wirklich 100% ringsrum sicheren Computer bauen. Also spätestens mit der Entdeckung von Covered Channels, also der Möglichkeit, an den geplanten Kommunikationskanälen vorbei zu kommunizieren, war halt vollkommen klar, dass man halt keine sicheren Computer bauen kann, beziehungsweise keine sicheren Multi-User-Systeme bauen kann. Bei diesen Wahlcomputern ist es halt so, die wurden halt, zumindest die Nedap-Kisten wurden halt so nach dem Prinzip designt wie so ein Spielautomat. Das heißt, es gibt einen Prozessor und einen Speicher und Tasten und ein Display und man versucht halt, die Funktionalität der Wahlen mit diesen Elementen abzubilden. Am Ende kommt dabei halt daraus, dass sie halt irgendwie gerade stolz geschafft haben, überhaupt diese Wahlen abzubilden, das heißt dafür zu sorgen, dass sie halt ein Prozedere, was halt dem Wählen mit dem Stimmzettel ähnlich ist, auf diesen Computern abgebildet bekommen haben und sich halt über Sicherheit nicht so richtig viele Gedanken machen konnten. Also die Dinger sind halt, wie Andreas Burk so schön sagte, schlechter gesichert als jeder Playstation, was halt irgendwie die Hardware angeht.
Sie stehen auch wirklich mehr in der Tradition der Spielmaschinen als...
Genau, aber selbst wenn sie halt wesentlich besser gesichert wären, nehmen wir mal an, sie hätten irgendwie die Güte, was weiß ich, von einer Xbox oder von einer Playstation, würde das Problem eigentlich nur verschlimmern, weil könnte immer noch niemand nachprüfen. Also der Kern der Kritik an diesen Wahlcomputern ist ja, eine Wahl mit Zettel und Stift, da kannst du auf die Straße gehen und greifst dir irgendjemand von der Straße und erklärst ihm, wie das geht und der kann eine Wahl mit Zettel und Stift auditieren. Da ist nachgucken, ist betrogen worden, wird richtig zusammengezählt, sind die ungültigen Stimmen richtig ausgewertet worden und so weiter und so fort. Eine Wahl mit Computern, da gibt es halt nur ganz wenige Experten, die das tatsächlich tun können. Da hast du halt nur eine sehr, sehr kleine Anzahl von Leuten, die wirklich so ein Computer inside out verstehen können, zur Not bis runter auf die Chip-Ebene. Weil wenn man halt von Manipulation spricht, muss man heute Hardware-Manipulation berücksichtigen. Und allein deswegen ist es halt eigentlich ein schlechteres System, weil du halt wesentlich weniger Leute hast, die das System überprüfen können.
So und eigentlich genau mit diesem Mindset hat sich diese Gruppe Wir vertrauen Wahlcomputern nicht gegründet, hat zunächst einmal Propaganda gemacht und dann kam das Ganze dann zu einem Punkt, wo auf einmal so Wahlcomputer auf dem Tisch standen. Wo kamen die denn her?
Naja, es gab halt noch vorher diesen lustigen kleinen Zwischenfall, dass eine Herstellerin von diesen Wahlcomputern, die Firma Nedap, sich halt provoziert fühlte, Stellung zu nehmen. Das heißt, die fühlten sich halt verpflichtet mal zu sagen, also mit unseren Wahlcomputern, die sagen mal so gerne Wahlmaschinen, weil es so mechanisch klingt, da geht sowas halt prinzipiell nicht. Das sind halt dedicated, special purpose machines, da kann man nichts anderes machen als wählen. Während die Initiative in Holland gesagt hat, das sind halt Computer, da können wir machen, was wir wollen. Und wir können auch Schach drauf spielen. Und Nedap hat dann halt verlaut mal lassen. Also Schach spielen, das würden sie doch zu gerne mal gezeigt bekommen, aber das ging halt eigentlich nicht, weil Hacker haben ja keine Chance. Und das sind halt dedicated, special purpose machines, da ist halt wirklich nichts zu reißen. Na ja, also war halt natürlich die Challenge, sich halt solche Kisten zu besorgen. Zuerst wurde halt ein Gerät irgendwoher geborgt von einer Gemeinde, die halt, naja, dem Anliegen sympathisch gegenüber stand. Und später wurden zwei Maschinen gekauft von einer Gemeinde, die zusammengelegt worden war, wo sie halt einfach welche überhatten.
Weil sie nur einen Bezirk freuten und zwei Geräte dafür hatten.
Ja, sie wollten wohl eine noch behalten als Spare. Und na jedenfalls gab es dann halt zwei Maschinen und zwei Wahlcomputer und eines von diesen Programmieregeräten, die man halt braucht, um diese Speichermodule, auf denen die Stimmen gespeichert werden, zu lesen und zu schreiben. Ich weiß gar nicht, aus welchen Fällen. Für die Gemeinde war es halt irgendwie ein akzeptabler Betrag, weil sie konnten dafür irgendwie einen neuen Sandkasten bauen. Und wir hatten halt auch den Spaß, dass die Dinger dann plötzlich da auf dem Tisch standen. Und kaum halt die Nachricht da, dass die Kisten halt in Amsterdam angekommen sind, ist dann halt eine kleinere Hordehacker aus Berlin dahin aufgebrochen, um da mal ein entspannter, längerer Wochenende zu verbringen mit den Kisten. Und halt mal als allererstes Schach zu implementieren, aus besagten Grund. Die hatten halt gesagt, Schach geht halt genau gar nicht. Also, dass man da halt erstmal die Schachter aufbringt.
Vielleicht sollten wir ja erstmal erklären, wie muss man sich jetzt so ein Gerät vorstellen? Also, wenn man da jetzt mal so hinkommt, also ich hab jetzt so ein Teil auch schon mal gesehen, das ist so ein großer Kasten, den kann man irgendwie aufklappen, dann mutiert der sozusagen zu seiner eigenen Wahlkabine, so mit links und rechts so klappen. Was kannst du da so, also wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also, die mechanische Konstruktion von dem Ding ist schon einigermaßen clever. Man hat halt hinten eine Computereinheit, da ist halt ein Mainboard drauf, einen Drucker und der Slot für die Stimmmodule. Dann gibt es daneben halt noch ein Netzteil und das liegt halt in so einer Muldel, wo die halt ein bisschen mit Schaumstoff gepolstert ist. Und das Mainboard ist halt in einer geschirmten Kiste, halt so einer Metallkiste mit den üblichen HF-Schirmungslaschen und da gehen dann halt die Kabel hoch. Und dann klappt da drüber schräg hoch so eine Tafel und in der Tafel sind halt Tasten drin, ich glaube 36x31 Tasten. Und über der befindet sich halt ein Display. Und man geht dann sozusagen rum um das ganze Ding, auf die andere Seite, auf die Seite, wo die Tasten sind und guckt halt auf das Display und hat dann da seine Stimmtasten, wo man halt die Kandidaten auswählen kann. Und dann sieht man oben im Display, welchen Kandidaten man gewählt hat. Dann gibt es halt noch eine Abstimm-Taste, um halt zu bestätigen, dass man jetzt abgestimmt hat. Zusätzlich dazu gibt es halt noch an einem langen Kabel so eine Kontrolleinheit, über die der Wahlleiter die Wahl halt kontrollieren kann, also das Gerät freischreiten kann.
Der Wahlleiter kann die Wahl kontrollieren.
Oder sagen wir die Wahlleiten. Also was er halt effektiv tut, ist, er schaltet halt den Computer frei zur Stimmabgabe. Das heißt also er sagt halt, du darfst jetzt abstimmen und sieht halt, ob du abgestimmt hast. Und muss dann halt für den nächsten wieder freischalten und dann gibt es da so Schlüsselschalter und noch so Tasten, mit denen man die Kiste halt in so einen Status bringt, dass sie dann halt zum Schluss das Ergebnis ausdruckt oder zum Beispiel im Testmodus, wo man eine Display und die Tasten testen kann. Und so, all solche Funktionen. Das ist halt so ein Computer mit zwei Displays und Schlüsselschalter und Tasten und so weiter und so fort.
Da sollte man kurz noch erwähnen, wie dieser Wahlvorgang also tatsächlich vorgeht.
Du hast es ja in Cottbus auch gesehen, ne?
Genau, man geht ja als Wähler ja hin. Und dieses Bedienpult ist halt dazu da, um die Maschine erstmal scharf zu schalten. Weil es kann ja auch nicht angehen, dass da hinten einer hingeht und zehnmal auf eine Taste drückt und dann hat er zehnmal gewählt. Und irgendwie muss das Gerät ja wissen, wann sozusagen ein neuer Wähler anfängt. Sprich, das Gerät wird vorher in einen stimmbereiten Modus gemacht. Das wird eben mit dieser Bedienkonsole getan, die so zwei, drei Meter entfernt ist von dem Gerät durch ein langes Kabel. Und dann darf eben die Person wählen, die dort hingegangen ist, indem sie eben die entsprechende Taste drückt. Und dann muss die dann auch nochmal bestätigt werden. Also es sind im Prinzip zwei Tastendrücke erforderlich, um jetzt eine einzige Auswahl zu machen.
Der Hintergrund ist, dass man sich halt auch korrigieren können soll. Also dass man halt, wenn man halt auf die Taste drückt, und die Taste drückt, dann kann man halt ins Display gucken und sehen, dass man möglicherweise das falsche gewählt hat. Und heißt, man hat dann noch die Stimmabgabetaste nochmal separat. Die ist in der Norderlande halt groß und rot und gibt einen satten Klack ab, wenn man da drauf drückt. In Deutschland ist das so eine pissige Folientaste, die irgendwie, also noch ist sie lustigerweise rot, in Deutschland ist sie grün. Das ist also auch so einer der lustigen Unterschiede. Und es gibt da halt noch einen Unterschied, denn in Holland ist halt die ungültig Taste oben links neben dem Display. In Deutschland wird die halt als normale Kandidatentaste konfiguriert. Das sind halt so die kleinen Unterschiede, die wir halt gesehen haben, nachdem wir die holländischen Geräte, die wir halt mit den Fingern hatten und die in Cottbus, die Deutschland vergleichen konnten.
Dieses Gerät ist halt einfach eine dedizierte Wahlmaschine an sich. Also das ist zumindest der Eindruck, den sie von außen erst mal macht.
Genau, bis man halt sozusagen mal unter die Haube schaut.
Du hast es jetzt schon gesagt, da ist so ein 68.000 Prozessor drin. Also im Prinzip ist das so Technologie von vor, was haben wir jetzt, 2006, 20, 15, 20, 15 Jahre.
15 Jahre ist es ungefähr. Also so halt so, nicht ZX, das ist so Atari ST Technologie. So ungefähr so die Technologien-Generation. Amiga, also so 87, 88 war das mal noch richtige Hightech. Und seitdem ist es halt kontinuierlich halt veraltet. Die Speicher, auf denen die Software drauf ist, sind halt so richtige E-Proms. Also so richtig so, noch so alte E-Proms, so wie man sie von früher kennt. Mit Auto und Even-Bank. Also sozusagen zwei Proms, auf denen halt die Software gespeichert wird.
Also quasi ein Nurlesespeicher, der eigentlich einen großen Speicherblock enthält, aber wo die ungeraden und geraden Bits verteilt sind auf zwei Chips aus technischen Gründen. Also da ist das feste Programm drin, das eigentliche Wahlsoftware.
Der Prozessor ist halt ein 16-Bit Prozessor und die E-Proms sind halt 8-Bit, deswegen brauchen wir halt zwei, um halt die 16-Bit abzubilden. Und plötzlich dazu gibt es noch ein bisschen RAM, also ein bisschen flüchtigen Speicher, sind glaube ich nur 16 Kilobyte, also nicht besonders viel. Und Flash, der befindet sich halt auf dem Stimmmodul, also auf diesem blauen Modul, so eine blaue Plastikiste, die ist ungefähr so groß wie zwei Zigaretten-Schachteln nebeneinander, ein bisschen flacher. Und daran befindet sich der Speicher, in dem zum einen die Konfiguration für die Stimmen drin ist, und zum anderen werden da die, also welche Kandidaten auf welchen Tasten liegen oder was im Display angezeigt wird. Und zum anderen werden da drin die Stimmen abgelegt, und zwar doppelt und jeweils invertiert, sodass man halt...
Das heißt, die Programmierung oder quasi die Vorbereitung der Maschinen für die Wahl erfolgt durch die entsprechende Speicherung einer Konfiguration in diesem Modul?
Korrekt, kann man halt rausnehmen, und das ist durch so ein Briefkastenschloss gesichert, um halt sicherzustellen, dass man nicht rausnehmen kann, weil das halt total leckerlich ist, weil das halt ein Briefkastenschloss ist. Also die Schlüssel bekommt man halt so für 50 Cent im Einschlägenfachhandel, und sie sind halt immer dieselben bei allen Kisten. Also was wir uns noch nicht geprüft haben, ist, ob die in Deutschland und Holland auch dieselben sind, oder ob die nur innerhalb der Länder dieselben sind.
Aber bei den holländischen Maschinen war es dann so, es ist immer dieselbe Schlüssel.
In Deutschland ja auch.
Und man konnte die dann auch gleich im Internet bestellen, die Schlüssel, weil das einfach so Standard ist, da muss man auch nicht mal was Besonderes angeben. Die schickt man dann so im 100er-Pack zugeschickt.
Das ist halt ein Standard-Schlüssel-Schalter. Also es ist überhaupt kein Problem. Und dann haben wir die Kiste aufgemacht. Und die Abschirmung ist halt schon relativ gut. Also es ist halt so eine Blechkiste mit so Laschen, die verhindern soll, dass da elektronische Abstrahlung rauskommt. Und dann ist halt dieses Mainboard, wo halt die Sachen raufgelötet sind, also der Drucker und die Fassungen für diese Stimmmodule und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn man auf diesen Mainboard guckt, denkt man so back in time. Also das letzte Mal, dass ich so was gesehen habe, war vor 15 Jahren oder so. Da sind halt richtig viele Chips drauf. Also heutzutage, wenn man so in den Computer reinguckt, hat man so ein paar große Chips. Und das war dann eigentlich so. Der Rest ist halt so Widerstände und so was. Da sind halt noch richtig doll viele Chips, also so richtig TDL-Chips. 74 hast du nicht gesehen. Wo halt einige wenige Logik-Gatter noch drauf sind, die halt dann halt die Funktion dieses Computers zusammensetzen. Also nicht so hoch integrierte Teile, wie man es heute kennt.
Könnte man natürlich sagen, okay, ist abgehangene Technik so? Da weiß man zumindest, was nicht funktioniert. In der Weltraumtechnik wird das ja ähnlich gemacht. Es zieht auch kein Chip hin, der es erst seit fünf Jahren gibt.
Ist halt schon so richtig abgehangen. Also ich meine, man kann es möglicherweise als Vorteil betrachten. Zum Beispiel auf Tomaten wird es ja ähnlich gehandhabt. Andererseits ist es halt auch so, dass durch das System weist keinerlei inhärente Sicherheitsfunktionen auf. Also es gibt halt nur prozedurale Sicherheiten. Also irgendwie, dass Sachen zweimal gespeichert werden oder so. Das ist halt eigentlich die gesamte Sicherheitskonstruktion des Gerätes auf Zuverlässigkeit. Das heißt, wir sicherstellen, dass die Stimmen wirklich alle gespeichert werden und dass keine verloren geht und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt von diesen Nedap-Kisten noch Varianten, die man auch aus dem Auto und dem Akku ausbetreiben kann, wenn der Strom ausfällt. Dann gibt es auch Zusatztasten für Behinderte und Braille-Zeilen für Blinde und all sowas. Also da gibt es noch eine ganze Menge Zusatz-Schnickschnacks, denen man noch dazu bestellen kann. Den haben wir aber nicht gesehen. Wir hatten tatsächlich diese zwei bzw. drei Wahlcomputer und das Programmiergerät. Das erste Ziel war, um uns mit den Geräten vertraut zu machen, Schacht drauf zu implementieren. Das heißt, wir wollten da einen Schacht drauf zum Spielen bekommen, um zu zeigen, dass es geht. Um zu zeigen, dass es ein normaler Computer ist wie der andere auch. Und dass man dadurch Schacht drauf spielen kann.
Das Display, wie groß ist das?
Das Display hat 40 Zeichen A und 4 Zeilen. Und jedes Zeichen ist aus 5 x 8 Pixel zusammengesetzt. Also es ist halt so ein Standard-Display.
Für einen Schachcomputer schon recht luxuriös. Also mein erster hatte deutlich weniger.
Ja, also wir haben halt auch experimentiert damit, ob wir dann ein Schachbrett darauf angezeigt bekommen. Aber haben uns dann halt auf die Standard-Schachnotation und halt Anzeige von uns weiter zurückgezogen. Der Plan war halt auf den Tasten vorne. Wir haben halt vorne dieses 36 x 31 Tastenfeld. Da halt die Touch-Tasten zu benutzen, um darauf halt die Figuren abzubilden. Andreas hat dann halt so ein superminiaturisierter Schach da in diese 16 Kilobyte-Speicher reingeprügelt. Erdgas hat dann mit dem Cross-Compiler danach irgendwie raufgeflanscht auf das Gerät. Es war halt auch erstmal nicht so einfach, eine Tool-Chain dafür zusammenzubauen, mit der man das überhaupt kompensieren kann.
Was war denn das Schach? Welches Schach wurde denn genommen?
Tiny-Chess, ja genau. Und Andreas musste dann irgendwie die Heuristiktabellen weglassen und solche Sachen tun. Und ich glaube, das Endspielmodul hat auch einen kleinen Knacks wegbekommen durch den fehlenden Speicher, aber am Ende konnte man halt irgendwie darauf spielen.
Habt ihr dann das ganze Spiel zu Ende gespielt, ist es ein leichter Gegner geworden?
Naja, das Problem ist halt, dass der mit dem Endspiel, also der kriegt halt nicht mehr so richtig mit, ob er matt war, zumindest in der Version, die wir am Anfang hatten. Ich glaube, mittlerweile wurde er noch wieder verbessert, aber so die erste Version hatte so ein paar Probleme mit der Erkennung des Schachmats. Aber darum ging es ja auch nicht. Sollte er nicht perfekt Schach spielen können, sollte er halt überhaupt nur Schach spielen können. Alles, der wirklich schwierigen Probleme war, wie macht man da ein Schachbrett drauf? Also so ein richtiges Schachbrett. Und wir hatten halt so verschiedene Ideen, Schachfiguren aus so magnetischer Folie ausschneiden und die dann da irgendwie aufbringen. Und dann haben wir halt so ein bisschen rum-exploriert. Und am Ende sind wir dann mit Rob von Erdgeist losgefahren und wir sind dann in Amsterdam in einen Schachladen gefahren und haben versucht, Schachfiguren zu kaufen. Magnetische Schachfiguren. Die gab es aber nur riesengroße Tasten, die hatten wir dann nicht drauf unterbekommen, weil die Tastenfelder sind auch relativ klein. Also die Tasten sind nur so einmal ein halb Zentimeter groß, also die aktive Fläche von diesen Tasten. Und naja, dann haben wir halt eine Schachfigur in den Kopf, die hatten halt keine Magneten drunter und haben dann noch, wir sind dann in so eine Shoppingstraße runter, dachten, ja, so, irgendwo muss es dir Magneten geben. Und Rob von Erdgeist hat mich schon für verrückt erklärt, weil ich einfach in jeden Laden rein bin, so einfach in wirklich jeden, so jeden Trödel-Wutz-Laden, wo es halt irgendwelchen Scheiß gibt. Hab dann endlich in einem Haushaltsladen Magneten gefunden und zwar so kleine Kühlschrank-Magneten. 64 Felder. 64 Felder, 32 Figuren. Aber das hat sozusagen auch nicht unser Problem gelöst, weil die Kiste selber, also diese Nedap-Tastenfelder, sind halt nicht magnetisch. Die sind halt aus Kopferblech. Magnetisch ist es halt nicht. Und dann haben wir versucht, wie will ich so ein magnetisches Fliegen, Gitter oder Plastematerial, was halt irgendwie magnetisierbar ist oder jedenfalls irgendetwas, worauf das hält. Und dann irgendwann habe ich halt diese Magneten ausgepackt und irgendwie, Erdgästentick hatten jeder so einen Magneten, dann haben wir halt wirklich so auf dieser Straße so alles, was irgendwie so magnetisch aussah, ausprobiert, ob das irgendwie geht. Und plötzlich holt Erdgäst den Magneten aus seiner Tasche raus und hat da so ein paar Cent-Stücken dran gehängt. Weil Cent-Stücken sind halt magnetisch. Und dann haben wir halt dann einfach ein Schachbrett ausgedruckt. Und dann haben wir halt unter jedem Feld ein Cent-Stück runtergeklebt mit Klebeband. Und haben das dann halt auf der Maschine so fixiert, dass die Cent-Stücken genau über den Tasten zu liegen kamen. Und dann haben wir noch die Magneten unter die Schachfiguren geklebt, sodass man halt einfach die Figuren auf den Cent-Stücken ein bisschen runtergedruckt hat. So wie man halt früher kannte, auf den Schachfiguren so runterdrücken, also von nach und dann hat er das halt erkannt über den Tastenfeld. Und also deinen Zug erkannt, dann musstest du noch die Abstimm-Taste drücken, um den Zug zu bestätigen.
Und dann hat er halt ein bisschen vor sich hin gerödelt und hat dann seinen Zug gesagt, den hat man dann einfach nur gesetzt.
Dann muss man nicht sozusagen mit runterdrücken bestätigen. Und dann konnte man auf Schach spielen. Und wir haben uns auch Mühe gegeben, wir haben halt auch die Tasten gemacht, wenn man halt einen Bauern durchbringt, dass man sich eine neue Figur wünschen kann und so weiter. Also man kann auch richtig drauf schach spielen. Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob das Endspielmodul mittlerweile fix ist. Es hat halt eine leichte Klatsche wegen zu wenig Erinnerungsverlust.
Auf jeden Fall war die Behauptung des Herstellers, man könne damit ja keinen Schach spielen, vollständig widerlegt. Und ihr hattet dann auch erst mal die notwendige Erfahrung gesammelt, wie denn diese Maschine eigentlich tatsächlich funktioniert. Dann ging es ja jetzt darum, auch mal die möglichen Manipuliermöglichkeiten zu demonstrieren.
Also der nächste logische Schritt war dann halt, das FROD-Modul zu implementieren. Das heißt also eine Software, die nach jedem Abstimmvorgang guckt, ob die Stimme, die da gerade abgegeben wurde, zu dem vorkonfigurierten Ergebnis passt und die dann halt entsprechend aufs Modul schreibt oder halt ändert und dann aufs Modul schreibt. Da gab es noch so ein bisschen Hackelein, bis wir die am Laufen hatten. Willem hat da ganz schön lange drin rumgehackt. Am Schluss ging es dann aber. Ich habe mich dann halt mit Barry mehr um den Tempestkram gekümmert. Ich teste diese Abstrahlungsmessungen, dass ich dir da die Details der Softwareentwicklung nicht so ganz live gesehen habe. Aber am Ende ist es halt so, dass eine Software herausgekommen ist, die man sagen kann, wie das Ergebnis in Prozent sein soll. Und der passt die abgegebenen Stimmen entsprechend an. Die Gesamtzahl der abgegebenen Stimmen stimmt immer. Und nur das Prozentergebnis wird entsprechend gewichtet, und zwar dynamisch, bis zum Ende des Abstimmvorgangs. Sodass zu jedem Zeitpunkt, wenn genug Stimmen drin sind, um ein Prozentergebnis gewichten zu können, das Ergebnis erzielt wird.
Sogar das Software Erinnern heißt, dass die Software dann letztlich in diesen E-Proms eingesetzt werden muss. Das heißt, um diese Manipulier-Attacke durchzuführen, muss man die E-Proms aus diesem Gerät herausziehen und durch andere ersetzen. Andere ersetzen, genau. Was wiederum Zugriff auf den Rechner erfordert. Aber wie lange dauert das dann? Klappe auf, Klappe zu, eine Minute?
Also, sagen wir mal, mit Siegel fällt schon vielleicht so etwas wie zweieinhalb Minuten. Also, wenn man es halt vorher geübt hat. Also, in der Softwareentwicklung haben wir mit EPROM-Summonatoren gearbeitet. Das sind so kleine EPROM-Dinger, die man auf die Socke hier raufsteckt und die halt ihren Inhalt über USB bekommen, sodass man halt schnelle Turn-Around-Cycles bei der Softwareentwicklung hat. Aber für so einen Fake würde man natürlich dann halt einfach richtige EPROMs nehmen. Die brennt man halt, dauert einen kleinen Augenblick. Hat man dann schon vorbereitet. Also, Klappe auf, EPROM raus, EPROM-Rinnenklappe zu, Siegel wieder drauf. 2,5, 3 Minuten würde ich so schätzen.
Und EPROM-Rennen muss man auch mal dazu sagen. Das mag für manche Leute jetzt wie Hightech vorkommen.
Das ist so richtige 80er-Jahre Technik.
Das ist so richtig, genau. 80er-Jahre Standard-Elektronik. Also, das beherrscht einfach jeder. Das ist so ein kleines Gerät. Da steckt man diesen Chip rein. Dann sagt man dem Computer, schickt die Daten dahin. Dann sind die in diesem Stein fest eingefangen. Und das ist alles kein Voodoo. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich im Prinzip auch der Grundansatz. Dass man sagt, okay, da läuft jetzt irgendeine Software. Ich drücke auf Taste A und ich möchte natürlich auch gerne, dass er jetzt eine Stimme für A zählt. Aber ich weiß es halt nicht, weil die Software kann ja auch entschließen, die beiden Tasten einfach zu vertauschen. Oder eben, wie in dem Fall, was ihr da demonstriert habt, sozusagen auch schon so eine gewisse statistische Manipulation da reinzubringen, um sicherzustellen, dass die Stimmen, also es ist nicht alles komplett erfunden, sondern die Anzahl der Wähler bleibt gleich, weil das würde ja schon auffallen, wenn er auf einmal sagt, da haben nur 50 gewählt, obwohl es 500 waren. Und dadurch, dass die Vorbereitungszeit auch so gering ist, also es war ja immer schwer in der Diskussion, wo stehen die Dinger eigentlich, sind die bewacht? Denn würde jetzt, sagen wir mal, ein böses Edeteam mit schwarzer Maske den Abend vor einer Wahl irgendwo hin marschieren, wo diese ganzen Rechner gelagert sind und würden dann irgendwie überall einmal die Software austauschen, dann wäre der Gauss schon extrem, weil dann könnte man eben auch die Wahlergebnisse so fein manipulieren, dass es nicht mehr auffällt im Ganzen.
Also dadurch, dass man halt die Software auch relativ komplex bauen kann, wäre halt selbst so ein Verfahren, dass man hingeht und sagt, okay, man nimmt sich halt ein paar von den Wahlcomputern aus den Wahllokalen raus und testet die, indem man halt darauf abstimmt und guckt, ob da ein anderes Ergebnis rauskommt. Selbst das wäre einfach erkennbar, weil so ein Test zwangsläufigerweise halt schneller wäre als im normalen Wahl. Das heißt, du hättest halt eine wesentlich höhere Abfolge von Abstimmvorgängen, als die bei der normalen Wahl üblich ist. Das kannst du problemlos erkennen und dann weißt du, okay, ich werde hier gerade getestet, ich mache mal gerade gar nichts. Das wäre halt problemlos möglich. Also du kannst halt, wenn du halt so eine Vorwort-Software schreibst, dir beliebige Maßnahmen ausdenken, mit denen du sich erstellen kannst, dass du halt nicht entdeckt wirst, ausser nimmst jemand wirklich die EPROMs raus und macht ein Binary Veryfine. Selbst dann, diese EPROMs sind echt verdammt groß. Also diese Bausteine sind nach heutigen Maßstäben riesig groß, für sehr wenig Speicher. Das heißt, es wäre überhaupt kein Problem, in so einen EPROM einen kompletten Prozessor einzubauen und noch mehr Speicher einzubauen, der einfach so tut, als wäre er ein EPROM, so und sich unter allen Umständen so ganz normal verhält, als wäre er ein EPROM, bis er halt irgendwie ein Signal bekommt, um sich halt dann halt in den Fort-Modus zu begeben und da kannst du dann halt auch nichts mehr testen.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir schon so ein bisschen in den Bereich der möglichen Attacken. Vielleicht bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei den Attacken, die ihr konkret auch durchgeführt bzw. praktisch gezeigt habt. Neben der Veränderung der Software, was ja relativ einfach war, hast du vorhin schon erwähnt, habt ihr auch eine Tempest-Analyse gemacht. Muss man erst mal erklären, was das ist?
Tempest ist auch als Van Eyck-Abstrahlung bekannt. Lustigerweise von einem holländischen Techniker. Zuerst publiziere ich den Herrn Van Eyck. Und zwar ursprünglich in der Diskussion war es als eine Methode, um den Inhalt von Bildschirmen aus der Ferne über die unabsichtlichen Abstrahlung dieses Monitors auszulesen. Jeder Bildschirm, egal ob LCD oder Röhre, hat eine spezifische Abstrahlung im Radiofrequenz-Spektrum, aus der man den Inhalt des Bildschirms rekonstruieren kann mit entsprechender Technologie. Man braucht einen relativ empfindlichen Empfänger und ein bisschen Kram, um das Bild wiederherzustellen.
Und zwar so in Echtzeit. Man steht so im Auto mit einer großen Antenne vorm Haus und man hat einfach denselben Bildschirminhalt wie derjenige, der da gerade vor sich hin tippt. Remote Desktop heißt du was heutzutage, glaube ich.
Nur, dass man nicht mal Netzwerk dazu braucht. Die Idee, die Barry hatte, war einfach mal zu gucken, gibt es da halt Abstrahlung von dem Ding? Wir haben einfach einen Scanner daneben erhalten.
Also einen Scanner mit einem Radio-Frequenz-Scan-Gerät.
Genau, einen Funkscanner, mit dem man halt breitbar nicht Funksignale empfangen kann und haben halt geguckt, was so zu hören ist und haben halt, also man hat dann festgestellt, dass die, bei den Holländern gibt es halt eine Partei, die ein Umlaut im Parteinamen hat. Und dieser Umlaut führt halt dazu, dass das Display in einer anderen Art und Weise angesteuert wird. Und diese andere Art der Ansteuerung führt dazu, dass die Refresh-Frequenz des Displays sich ändert. Das heißt, dass es in diesem Falle langsamer refreshed wird. Normalerweise wird es mit 75 Hz, ich glaube, 74 Hz, gerefreshed. Und wenn ein Umlaut drin ist, nur mit 58 Hz. Was dazu führt, wenn man auf der richtigen Frequenz ist, dann kann man diesen Unterschied tatsächlich auch hören. Das heißt, es gibt halt ein unterschiedliches Geräusch auf dieser Frequenz, je nachdem, ob ein Umlaut im Display ist oder nicht.
Ich kann das ja mal hier kurz einspielen, dann hören wir das auch.
Das ist genau, also man hat halt diese beiden unterschiedlichen Frequenzen gehört.
Guck mal, ich nehm mal ne andere.
Genau, und jetzt schaltet es gleich um. Also man hört halt deutlich die Unterschiede.
Und der, das Brummen ist jetzt das Brummen des Displays oder des gesamten Computers?
Das ist das Brummen vom, jetzt hören wir es nochmal auf der Straße. Also man kann das halt auch über eine einigermaßen große Entfernung empfangen mit der richtigen Antenne. Was man halt hört, ist tatsächlich das Brummen des Refresh-Zyklus des Displays. Das Display muss ja immer wieder erneuert werden, damit es halt was darstellt. Und wenn halt ein Umlaut dabei ist, wird diese Darstellung halt verlangsamt, weil halt der Umlaut halt als Bitmuster übertragen werden muss. Und das ist das, was man da hört. Wir haben halt noch eine Menge andere Sachen gefunden. Also wenn man halt mit der richtigen Antenne und dem richtigen Geduldsniveau da eine Weile mit spielt, kann man halt auch so Sachen hören, wie zum Beispiel die Tasten, die gedrückt werden. Man kann den, also was ich da noch gefunden habe, mit ein bisschen länglicher Analyse, war halt ein Muster. Und zwar immer bevor sich der Display-Inhalt ändert, gibt es so einen Klick, der ist ungefähr 200 Millisekunden lang, und in diesem Klick befindet sich der Display Setup-Paket. Das heißt, die Daten, die vom Computer zum Display-Controller geschrieben werden, bevor die ins Display gehen. Also der neue Display-Inhalt wird da reingeschrieben. Und der ist zwar bei Serialtesten, man kann den nicht per se dekodieren, ohne weiteres, aber der unterscheidet sich halt für die meisten Display-Inhalte so signifikant, dass man die profilen kann. Das heißt also, dass halt dieses Paket, was da kommt, wenn man halt mit einem einfachen Audio-Analysator analysiert, kriegt man halt unterschiedliche Muster raus, je nachdem, was im Display steht. Man kann es auch wieder finden. Dass der selbe Display-Inhalt angezeigt wurde, konntet ihr im Pattern von diesem 200-millisekunden-Paket erkennen. Das heißt also, wenn man da noch ein bisschen Software draufschmeißt, kann man ein Problem, muss halt auch eine richtige Analyse machen. Und genau sagen, was halt im Display steht.
Okay, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, ja gut, aber wenn ich zuhöre, dann kann ich ja die Wahl nicht manipulieren. Aber hier kommen wir ja zum anderen Problembereich, den Wahlcomputer hier wieder tangieren, nämlich die Versicherung der geheimen Wahl. Genau, man will nicht dabei beobachtet werden, wie man wählt, weil ja niemand wissen darf, was man wählt. Und das darf man deshalb nicht wissen. Das ist auch etwas, was vielen Leuten nicht klar ist. Das habe ich in Gesprächen immer wieder festgestellt. Wie geheime Wahl ist vor allem. Deshalb wichtig, damit man eben nicht erpresst wird oder gezwungen wird, um etwas zu wählen oder eben bezahlt war.
Oder seine Stimme verkaufen kann.
Genau. Und das wäre ja dadurch möglich. Das heißt, es kommt jemand in das Wahllokal und er drückt irgendwie Taste X für die Partei, die jetzt gerade mal bestellt wurde. Und da draußen steht jemand mit einer Antenne und stellt fest, ah, alles klar, hat er auch tatsächlich gemacht. Und dann kriegt er halt auch seine Betrag X dafür in die Hand gedrückt. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was man verhindern muss. Das ist ja auch ein großes Problem bei diesem anderen Wahnsinn, der uns ja noch bevorsteht mit E-Voting, wählen zu Hause, so am eigenen heimischen Viren verseuchten PC. Da ist das Ganze ja nochmal ein viel größeres Problem. Aber da wollen wir jetzt erstmal nicht drauf eingehen. Ich denke, das werden wir in der Zukunft nochmal genauer auseinandernehmen müssen, weil der Bahn endet ja nie. Also diese Tempest-Abstrahlung war dann auf jeden Fall ein ziemlicher Schlag ins Gesicht. Das heißt, die Dinger können weder die Geheimhaltung der Wahl sichern, noch eine Manipulierbarkeit verhindern.
Interessant ist halt, dass die, wir haben ja dann, nachdem der Bericht publiziert wurde, haben wir den ja auch in Deutschland publiziert. Und daraufhin hat die PTB, also die Physikal- und Technische Bundesanstalt, die halt die Nedap-Kisten in Deutschland geprüft hat, eher gesagt, also bei uns ist es anders. Und zwar hätten sie halt diese, diese Abstrahlungssicherheit wäre Bestandteil der Prüfung gewesen und da hätten sie darauf geachtet. Das ist halt noch so eines der großen Unbekannten, die wir momentan haben. In der Tat ist es halt so, dass die deutschen Nedap-Kisten ein bisschen anders sind. Die haben zum Beispiel Folientesten statt normaler Testen. Was halt ein Hinweis darauf sein könnte, dass sie halt von diesen Tempest-Problemen nicht so in diesem Maße betroffen sind. Auf der anderen Seite ist es halt so, dass die Folientasten kann man halt besser abschürmen als normale Tasten. Das ist der Hintergrund. Also normale Tasten aus Plastofolientasten ist halt eine metallische Fläche. Die kann man halt besser zum Abschürmen benutzen. Individet halt tatsächlich hilft gegen Tempest. Das wissen wir nicht. Wir haben noch keine deutschen Maschinen in den Händen gehabt. Das müssen wir halt noch mal versuchen, irgendwo herzukriegen. Und darüber dann halt zu gucken, ob wir da was sehen oder ob die PTB in diesem Fall ausnahmsweise halt mal tatsächlich die Wahrheit gesagt hat.
PTB sollten wir vielleicht auch noch mal ins Feld führen. Die Physikalisch-Technische Bundesanstalt. Wir hatten das am Chaosradio über Wahlcomputer, Chaosradio 117 hatten wir das Thema auch schon mal angeschnitten. Die sind ja diejenigen, die diese Wahlgeräte zulassen. In Deutschland ist das Gesetz entsprechend so.
Die die Untersuchung machen, nach der die Zulassung durch das Innenministerium erfolgt wurde.
Ja, richtig, das Innenministerium lässt sie zu, aber die Untersuchung muss halt die PTB durchführen. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch eher so diese Historie von Spielautomaten. Weil auch um sowas kümmert sich die PTB. Aber es ist halt absurd, weil ja eigentlich für Computersicherheit und davon muss man ja hier eigentlich reden, wenn wir von Wahlcomputern rechnen, müsste eigentlich das BSI zuständig sein.
Eigentlich sollte man denken, dass das BSI da halt zuständig ist, weil die sind ja halt nun für die Sicherheit von regierungskritischen Infrastrukturen verantwortlich im Computerbereich. Das BSI weiß glaube ich auch selber nicht, warum sie dazu nicht gefragt wurden. Das scheint glaube ich eher so die traditionelle Kugellei zwischen dem alten Automatenhersteller Nedap und irgendwie der für Automaten und Spielautomaten abnahm zuständige PTB gewesen zu sein.
Es gab ja auch nicht elektronische Wahlmaschinen. Es gibt ja auch mechanische Wahlmaschinen, die Deutschland auch zum Einsatz kamen.
Sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen. Das interessiert mich auch mal.
Ja, ich habe hier noch so ein lustiges Video aus den USA. Da war es ja auch schon seit Ewigkeiten im Einsatz. Also mechanisch mit Schiebern und Klackern und Holz.
Wo dann so eine Lochkarte rauskommt und die teilen auch das Problem mit diesen hängigen Chefs, was sie da bei der letzten Wahl hatten. Da standen sie doch da und haben geguckt, ob das jetzt durchgestanzt ist oder nur angestanzt ist.
Also Stansen oder mechanische Computer wurden da zum Einsatz gebracht. Solche ähnlichen Wahlhilfen, ich will es jetzt gar nicht mal Wahlgeräte nennen, gab es halt auch in Deutschland. Und da kommt das wahrscheinlich her. Die haben einfach versäumt, diesen Wechsel von Gerät zu Computer, von Maschine, von normalem, tumpen, mechanischem Bau hin zu komplexer Elektronik mit einer Vielzahl an Modifikationsmöglichkeiten, den korrekt nachzuvollziehen. Da habe ich ein gewisses Verständnis dafür, dass man das eine Weile nicht begreift, aber bitte nicht im Jahr 2006. Das Thema muss jetzt langsam echt mal vom Tisch. Und wir haben also jetzt diese Bedrohung durch die Wahlcomputer.
Amsterdam hat ja mehr oder minder indirekt auch gesagt, dass sie halt die BSI jetzt auch hinzuziehen werden. Zur Prüfung der Nedap-Teile. Und da kann man einfach nur sagen, wenn die BSI auch nur einen Funken tatsächlich von professioneller Ehre im Leib hat, dann werden sie irgendwie, nachdem sie nach einer halben Stunde am Schreibtisch gelachend gelegen haben, irgendwie sagen, ich schmeiß den Scheiß weg. Also die brauchen einfach nur ihr IT-Grundschutz-Hatbruch rausnehmen und da mal reingucken. Und dann wissen sie, dass das halt eigentlich nicht geht.
Ja, wir sollten nochmal auf das Presseecho kommen. Aber vorher wollte ich nochmal kurz aufgreifen, was ich da vertagt hatte, nämlich die möglichen Angriffsszenarien. Also ihr habt jetzt quasi Software-Manipulierbarkeit und Abhörbarkeit bei den Maschinen ganz gut nachgewiesen. Es gibt ja auch ein ausführliches, mehrseitiges Paper, wo das alles schön zusammengefasst ist. Das gibt es alles bei... Wir vertrauen Wahlcomputer nicht auf wlndisch.
Wir haben es auch alles auf ww.cde verlinkt.
Und natürlich wie immer, das lohnt sich immer zu erwähnen, in den Lyrics von dieser mp3-Datei, die ihr gerade hört, steht das alles drin, oder auf der Webseite von chaosradioccc.de findet ihr immer alle Links zu dem, worüber wir hier gerade reden. Das wird einmal schön fleißig reingefügt. Jetzt habe ich den Paden verloren. Ach ja, genau, die möglichen Angriffe. Die möglichen Szenarien, die man sich jetzt noch so vorstellen kann. Du hast ja angefangen mit diesem, ich sage mal, das Trojanische Prinzip, dass man quasi in diese Maschine oder in die einzelnen Bauteile etwas ganz anderes reinbaut, als es da eigentlich reingehört, zumindest nicht nur.
Also die Komplexität der möglichen Angriffe ist nahezu unendlich. Also man kann halt jeden einzelnen Chip auf diesem Gerät oder diesen Computer dahingehend modifizieren, dass er etwas ganz anderes tut, als er soll, indem man halt einfach einen anderen einbaut. Dadurch, dass diese Bausteine da drauf halt so alt sind und so riesengroß sind, kann man da problemlos modernen Elektronik mit viel höherer Komplexität unterbringen. Also Beispiel halt zum Beispiel ein EEPROM, der halt einen kompletten Prozessor enthält und halt ganze Dinge owned, also der halt vom EEPROM aus sozusagen diesen kompletten Wahlcomputer steuert. Man könnte halt zum Beispiel auch hingehen, was eine sehr elegante und realitätstaugliche Attacke wäre und ein throianisches Stimmmodul bauen. Das heißt also, dass dieses wechselbare blaue Modul, auf dem die Stimmkonfiguration abgelegt wird und auf dem die Stimmen gespeichert werden, einen eigenen Prozessor enthält und mit diesem Prozessor könnte man dann zum Beispiel einfach die Stimmspeicherung selbst in diesem Modul manipulieren.
Das heißt also, anstatt dass die Software tatsächlich in einen Flash-Speicher schreibt, übergibt sie die Daten nur an einen Computer, der sagt, hahaha, dich habe ich aber gelimt und speichert halt ganz was anderes.
Genau, der kann sogar einfach die Daten korrekt speichern und gibt erst in dem Augenblick, wo er abgefragt wird, zum Beispiel für den Ausdruck von dem Wahlergebnis bzw. beim Auslesen in der Programmierkiste, gibt er dann halt jetzt das falsche Ergebnis aus. Die Software muss selbst bei einer Prüfung zwischendrin, wenn jemand ein Modul rausnimmt und guckt, ob alt oder in Ordnung, sieht er nichts. Erst in dem Augenblick, wo das Ergebnis angefordert wird, kommt da halt ein falsches Ergebnis raus. Und dann kannst du dreimal die Software auf dem Wahlcomputer prüfen, da passiert genau gar nichts, da siehst du nichts. Du kannst irgendwie dieses Stimmmodul ausnahmenden, du siehst immer noch nichts, weil den Chip kannst du halt in eine Mehrlagenleiterplatte dazwischen laminieren, wenn du möchtest heutzutage.
Und man kann natürlich auch in die großen Chips, also gerade die CPU, die finde ich ja ganz toll, die 68.000er CPU, wer sich da noch erinnert, das ist halt eine riesen Gehäuse. Also für heutige Maßstäbe, da würde man also wirklich mehrere Hochleistungs-Desktop-PCs heute reinbekommen. Also komplette PCs auf einem Chip und davon passen da mehrere rein. Und da passt also auch noch eine Antenne rein, da passt Speicher rein, man kann da irgendwie alles machen, was du willst. Und trotzdem würde sich das Ding nach außen verhalten wie ein stinknormaler Motorola 68.000.
Ich finde ja die Attacke über das Stimmmodul auch deswegen cool, weil die halt außerhalb der Abschirmung ist. Weil für das Stimmmodul ist das halt eine Plastegehäuse und das guckt halt aus der Abschirmung raus. Das heißt also, du könntest da auch noch einen Funkcontroller unterbringen in diesem Stimmmodul oder was auch immer. Das sind halt so zwei Plasteschalen, die eine Leiterplatte abdecken. Das ist halt so eine richtig schlimme 80er-Hert-Technologie. Das ist also kein Gehäuse im eigentlichen Sinne. Du hast halt so eine Leiterplatte, und unten direkt an der Leiterplatte ist der Stecker angelötet. Da muss man sich ungefähr vorstellen, das sieht halt aus wie so ein Nintendo Game-Konsolen-Modul. Also wie so ein Modul, was man halt zu einem alten Nintendo reinsteckt. Ziemlich genau so, nur halt in blau. Und so auch so eine Leiterplatte mit zwei Plasteschalen. Und das war es eigentlich so. Und da guckt auch nie jemand rein. Die Dinger sind nicht versiegelt. Die sind halt durch einen Briefkassenschlüssel gesiegelt, in der Maschine verriegelt. Das heißt, man kann die Problemluster rausholen. Und dadurch hat man auch keinerlei Schwierigkeiten, da halt beliebige Manipulationen darauf unterzubringen. Also das ist noch so eine Attacke, die wir halt zeitlich einfach nicht geschafft haben. Aber die, falls die sich immer noch weiter wehren, dann werden wir das halt einfach implementieren.
Da kommen wir jetzt im Prinzip auch schon wirklich auf das Echo. Eins der Echoes, der doch sehr nervösen Wahlcomputerhersteller war, ja im Prinzip dieses, naja, dass das manipulierbar war. Das hätten wir euch auch gleich vorher sagen können. Also schon mal eine sehr interessante Feststellung, die da der deutsche Vertreter von Nedap hier in Deutschland, das HSG-Wahlgerät.
Er hätte sich gewundert, warum es so lange gedauert hat, hat er gesagt.
Und da können wir ganz klar antworten, es braucht halt ein paar Tage.
Wir hatten halt nicht so viel Zeit und ihr habt uns vorher keine Kisten gegeben.
Das ist der Grund. Genau. Und das war natürlich schon mal eine sehr interessante Feststellung. Eine andere interessante Feststellung finde ich, dieses Behaaren auf, naja, es kann zwar rein theoretisch natürlich immer was schiefgehen, aber wir haben ja so super sichere Rahmenbedingungen für das ganze Handling und wie die Maschinen gelagert werden und so weiter und wie damit umgegangen wird. Und da kann halt gar nichts schiefgehen. Nun war vor ein paar Tagen eine Wahl, eine ganz besondere Wahl, eine Wahl, von der wahrscheinlich normalerweise in Deutschland keiner wirklich nennenswert Notiz genommen hätte. Die Oberbürgermeisterwahl in Cottbus musste neu ausgefochten werden, nachdem dort vor einiger Zeit die herrschende Oberbürgermeisterin abgewählt wurde. Die mochten die alle nicht, da wurde die abgewählt. Jetzt war eine neue Wahl. Die Besonderheit in Cottbus ist, dass dort flächendeckend in 69 Wahlbezirken diese Computer zum Einsatz kamen. Wir sind dann da hin und haben uns den ganzen Vorgang angeschaut. Wir waren ja getrennt unterwegs. Was waren denn deine Eindrücke jetzt? Und zwar konkret mal auf diese Sache mit dem Stimmmodul-Handling und den möglichen Zugriffsmöglichkeiten auf das Gerät, mit dem man jetzt eine der von euch skizzierten oder von uns gerade ausgedachten Manipulationsmöglichkeiten oder Betrugsattacken hätte vornehmen können.
Na, die Wahlleiterin von Cottbus, wie ist die Frau? Hatte ja vorher, muss wohl aus dem Urlaub genau gekommen sein, als dieses Papier, was mit den Holländern zusammengemacht haben, publiziert wurde, hat ja daraufhin offensichtlich die PTB gebeten, die Cottbusser Wahlcomputer nochmal einzeln zu überprüfen. Weiterhin wurde dann halt bekannt gegeben, dass die nochmal einzeln versiegelt seien. Wir sind dann halt irgendwie da in aller Herrgott zu früh aufgestanden, um uns halt den Aufbau dieser Wahlcomputer in den Wahlokalen anzugucken. Das erste, was ich da antraf, war, naja, so ein Hausmeister, der war halt, na wie so ein Hausmeister halt so ist, zur frühen Morgenstunde halt schon so ein bisschen im Tee. Und naja, und beschwerte sich so ein bisschen darüber, dass er zu früh aufstehen musste, weil irgendwie diese blöden Wahlcomputer wurden halt schon so früh angeliefert und so. Und naja, und wie sich dann herausgestellt hat, er hat tatsächlich den Wahlcomputer von diesem Wahllokal angenommen und den dann wieder hingestellt.
Das heißt, diese Maschinen werden frühmorgens von einem uns nicht bekannten zentralen Ort aus in die Wahlbezirke verschickt.
Genau, die würden dann halt irgendwie mit städtischen Autos oder so hingefahren.
Einem oder mehreren.
Wissen wir nicht. Und stehen dann halt erstmal. So, also Constanze zum Beispiel stand da halt eine Weile mit ihrem Computer alleine. Da war halt keiner, nur der Hausmeister irgendwie so. Bis dann halt mal der Wahlvorstand eintrodelt hat.
Okay, aber der ist ja versiegelt.
Genau, der ist versiegelt mit einer Bleiplombe, auf der auf der einen Seite SVC für Stadtverwaltungen Cottbus und auf der anderen Seite OBW für Oberbürger weiß es aber als Stich. Also die Plombe kommt glaube ich von irgendwie plombe24.de und man kriegt da so für 110 Euro ungefähr ein komplettes Kit, mit dem man halt irgendwie diese Plomben nachmachen kann. Also das ist halt lächerlich. Es gibt aktuell einen Energieversorger, nicht mehr für seinen Gastzähler sowas, weil irgendwie sie wissen, dass es zu einfach nachzumachen ist. Na gut, also damit stand dann jedenfalls mit dieser Hochsicherheitsplombe, das Gerät da unter der Hauptruthane des leicht alkoholischen Hausmeisters umher, was sicherlich voll unter die Definition von geschützter Umgebung fällt, die halt...
Das heißt, man hätte, sie hätte jetzt sogar ohne Probleme die Plombe aufmachen können, die Kisse leicht aufklappen, da muss man gar nicht so viel heben, um da ranzukommen, wenn ich das richtigen Änderungen habe.
Genau, man muss es halt so ein bisschen anheben und...
Ein bisschen anheben, ein bisschen Plastedeckelklappe aufmachen und dann hat man das Stimmmodul im Prinzip schon direkt im Zugriff, wenn man einen Schlüssel hat. Aber der Schlüssel ist ja bekannt, das ist ja überall derselbe.
Und der liegt dabei.
Ach ja, und der liegt dabei?
Der liegt also in der Kiste dabei.
Perfekt gesichert.
Genau, also die Sicherheit...
So, das heißt, hätte man jetzt so ein trojanisches Stimmmodul, hätte man das einfach reinschieben können, haben wir natürlich nicht gemacht, weil wir sind ja...
Genau.
Wir sind ja nicht böse und niemand hätte es gemerkt.
Also, die haben wir immer behauptet, es wurde alles nur in geschützten Umgebungen behandelt und wäre halt alles schrecklich sicher und nur vertrauenswürdige Leute und alles ganz schrecklich geheim. Aber am Ende war es halt irgendwie ein städtischer Bediensteter mit seinem Vermessungsfahrzeug und ein Hausmeister.
Okay, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, gut, das war eine Ausnahme. Das soll nicht passieren. Und wir verbessern nochmal unsere Prozeduren und machen die Ansage besser.
Das war halt keine Ausnahme. Das war halt so, dass wir das an mehreren Wahllokalen gesehen haben, dass es halt genauso lief.
Na gut, aber du weißt ja, wie das ist so in der Reaktion.
Okay, also man kann...
Jetzt kann man halt sehen, okay...
Man kann halt den Wahlvorstand auch eine halbe Stunde früher hinschicken. Das würde sicherlich gehen. Das wurden die zwar nicht toll finden, aber das würde halt gehen.
Na gut, aber vor allem sagen wir mal, als potenzieller Angreifer kann ich mich natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt darauf verlassen, dass es so ist. Es kann auch sein, dass der Hausmeister die ganze Zeit da draufsitzt und sagt, nö, sie kommen hier gar nicht rein, bis der Wahlvorstand da ist. Das kann ja passieren. Darauf kann man sich nicht verlassen.
Andererseits ist es halt auch so, dass man als potenzieller Angreifer ist man in der Regel halt auch kein Innentäter, sondern als potenzieller Angreifer ist man halt ein Innentäter.
Das heißt, das Stimmmodul ist schon ausgetauscht, bevor es beim Hausmeister landet.
Genau. Das heißt also, in dieser hochgeheimen Wahlzentrale wird das halt vorbereitet. Wie die Prozeduren da aussehen, wissen wir nicht. Da müssen wir nochmal eine IFG-Anfrage stellen. Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Genau. Uns mal diese Prozeduren und die Protokolle dazu schicken lassen. Was sie bestimmt nicht mögen werden, aber da schauen wir mal. Also der gesamte Ansatz, den sie da gefahren haben, war zu sagen, wir haben jetzt hier diese Wahlcomputer und diese blöden Hacker haben bewiesen, dass man die manipulieren kann. Und dann war auch noch der Hersteller so trottlich hinzuzugeben, dass man die manipulieren kann. Die PTB hat gesagt, wir können es manipulieren. Das Innenministerium hat gesagt, naja, das wird wohl was dran sein. Also müssen wir uns darauf verlassen, dass niemand an diese Kisten rankommt, um sie zu manipulieren. Das war halt so die Logik, die dahinter steht. Und was wir gezeigt haben, ist, dass sie dazu nicht in der Lage sind. Also es gibt halt keine Möglichkeit zur Überprüfung. Also die Wahlvorstände in den Wahllokalen hatten keinerlei Möglichkeit, auch nur im Ansatz irgendwie zu prüfen, dass diese Maschine okay ist. Die haben halt geguckt, dass da null Stimmen drinsteht. Das heißt also, dass die gebootet haben, dass da steht, null Stimmen im Speicher. Dann haben sie halt hier Hähnchen aus Protokoll gemacht und unterschrieben.
Also die haben auch noch die Wahlbezirksnummer verglichen.
Und die ID des Stimmmoduls haben sie geprüft.
Im besten Fall, ja. Und die ID von dem Gerät selber auch noch. Und wenn sie richtig pfiffig waren, haben sie vielleicht noch eine Softwareversionsnummer angeschaut. Plus, das ist auch so absurd, der Vergleich erfolgt ja mit dem Bong, der dabei liegt. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man als Innentäter die Möglichkeit hat, diese Maschinen umfangreich zu manipulieren, kann man natürlich auch alle Rahmenparameter entsprechend anpassen und dann stimmt halt dieser Zelt.
Aber selbst als Außentäter könnte man einfach den Zettel beiliegen, weil er liegt halt einfach bei. Das ist irgendwie so ein Lebensschlüssel. Gesichert von der tollen Bleibombe von Plomme24D.
Es ist da einfach kein wirkliches Sicherheitskonzept zu entdecken. Man muss vielleicht zur Verteidigung der Leute in Cottbus sagen, die machten jetzt alle nicht gerade einen besonders verschwörerischen Eindruck. Die waren eigentlich eher nervös, natürlich vollkommen verstört durch die Diskussion im Vorfeld. Sie haben sich allerdings auch zu so unüberprüfbaren Aussagen hinreißen lassen, dass ihre Wahlcomputer ja sicher sind mit drei Ausrufezeichen.
Die haben halt Copy und Paste von der Presseerklärung von Nedap gemacht. Diese Erklärung von Hickel hat halt Copy und Paste aus dem gemacht, was die Leute von HSG Wahlsysteme, dem deutschen Distributor von Nedap, gesagt haben. Also die Formulierung von dieser geschützten Umgebung und so. Und selbst die drei Ausrufezeichen, das ist halt einfach so genau Nedap Speak.
Ach, die drei Ausrufezeichen waren schon in der Original? Aber ich glaube, das war so eine Vermutung. Aber ich meine, was man hier ganz gut sieht, ist, wir brauchen einfach mehr Aufmerksamkeit auch bei den Gemeinden. Weil letzten Endes sind es die, die gelingt werden, wenn Wahlergebnisse nicht stimmen.
Also am Ende läuft es darauf hinaus, dass die Gemeinden wollen diese Wahlcomputer halt haben, weil sie ihre öffentlichen Bediensteten da nicht noch 3 Stunden länger sitzen lassen wollen. Und die wollen ja Ergebnisse schneller haben. Das ist der Grund. Arbeitserleichterung. Genau, also Nedap versucht den halt einzureden, dass es billiger ist. Das hat sich mittlerweile erledigt. Wenn die PTB da mal anrücken muss und jeder einzelnen Wahlcomputer prüfen muss, dann ist es nicht billiger.
Die Kosten sind ja auch so in Holland gestiegen.
Genau, in Holland sind die Kosten auch noch gestiegen. Ich hoffe nur in Deutschland, dass die PTB tatsächlich den Gemeinden die Rechnung schickt für diese Sonderprüfung. Mit dem Billiger kriegen sie nicht mehr argumentiert. Worum es nur noch geht, ist am Ende, dass die Wahlvorstände schnell nach Hause wollen. Ihr könnt das auch verstehen. Wir haben das gesehen. Für uns war das auch eine ganz schön lange Zeit da an Cottbus. Wir konnten zwischendurch noch was essen gehen und uns entspannen und ein bisschen im Park sitzen und mit der Wahlleiterin telefonieren und ähnliche Unterhaltungen, während die da die ganze Zeit hier sitzen haben und darauf gewartet haben, dass da mal Wähler kommen. Und wenn sie dann noch hinter ihr hingehen müssen und nochmal alle auszählen, ist halt schon ziemlich lästig. Aber das lässt sich organisatorisch durchaus regeln. Also man könnte ja hingehen und sagen, okay, man arbeitet halt zum Beispiel in Vier-Stunden-Schichten und für die Auszählung kommt nochmal ein Extra-Team dahin. Oder dergleichen Dinge mehr. Das lässt sich ja alle problemlos organisieren. Oder man gibt ihnen halt einfach mal ein bisschen mehr Geld. Also ich weiß nicht, wie da ist. In Berlin ist es jetzt so, dass die öffentlich Bediensteten, die da halt häufiger vergattert werden, die Wahlhilfe zu machen, kriegen halt dann auch einen Abrummeltag. Das heißt, wenn die da den Sonntag sitzen, ist halt seitens des Sonntags Dienst gemacht. Das heißt, die kriegen halt dann auch einen Tag mehr frei.
Gibt es auch so ein tolles Wort für diese Vergütung, ne?
Essensgeld. Naja, also ich weiß, es ist für irgendwie Leute, die der Demokratie helfen, halt einfach mal verdammt wenig und eigentlich auch nicht einzusehen. Also ich finde, das ist... Ich meine, Herrgott, wenn es jetzt doppelt so viel kostet, weil irgendwie die Leute ordentlich Geld da kriegen, wenn wir das hier den ganzen Tag sitzen und auf die Wahlen aufpassen, Herrgott, das muss Demokratie halt wert sein. Also da denke ich, das Grundprinzip, dass Wahlen halt nicht ein optimierungsbedürftiges Ding sind, das halt, worum es eigentlich geht. Also wir haben halt... Nedap geht ja hin mit den Wahlcomputern und der Grundbehauptung, ja, also diese Wahlen, die sind halt irgendwie teuer und lästig und man muss da halt mal dran drum optimieren. Da muss man halt rationalisieren und computerisieren und streamlinen und dafür sorgen, dass die halt irgendwie nicht mehr so viel Geld kosten. Das ist eigentlich nicht einzusehen. Das ist halt nicht so. Wahlen ist halt so eines der wenigen letzten heiligen Güter in dieser Demokratie. Und da muss man nichts optimieren. Da muss man nichts streamlinen. Die müssen auch nicht billiger werden. Die können von mir sogar teurer werden. Habe überhaupt gar kein Problem damit. Wenn sich hier gestellt ist, dass die halt geheim nachvollziehbar, nachprüfbar sind und frei sind. So dass man halt einfach die Grundlagen der Demokratie erhält, darf halt auch gerne Geld kosten. Und das ist, glaube ich, was Nedap schlicht nicht verstanden hat.
Ja, und das ist auch das, was leider die Gemeinden nicht verstehen, die sich halt davon abhalten lassen. Sie kriegen natürlich auch ein bisschen Rückendeckung. Wir haben ja danach ein paar Befragungen gemacht bei den Wählern selbst und mal geguckt, wie denn das so gesehen wird. Und es war schon erschreckend. Also erschreckend und beruhigend gleichermaßen, denn alle hatten eigentlich so ein Grundvertrauen in das System. Das ist mir fast lieber als die viel beschworenen amerikanischen Zustände, wo irgendwie Grundvertrauen in das System eigentlich nicht existiert. Das brauchen wir auch. Bloß, wenn man sich dann halt ein wenig mit ihnen unterhalten hat und ihnen sozusagen mal klargemacht haben, dass sie gerade eine Wahl begangen haben, die sich nicht nachzählen lässt.
Eine Wahl begangen ist auch sehr schön.
Eine Wahl, an einer Wahl teilgenommen. Wie auch immer. Also, dass ihre Aktion als solche zwar vielleicht unter Umständen gezählt wurde, aber vielleicht unter Umständen auch nicht. Und dass es keine Möglichkeit gibt, das nachzuvollziehen. Da kamen dann eigentlich alle erst ins Grübeln, weil sie einfach überhaupt nicht verstanden haben, dass sie ein Computer waren. Und auch die Frage danach, was sie denn glauben, wie diese Geräte tatsächlich funktionieren, hat eigentlich selten irgendwelche sinnvollen Ergebnisse gebracht. Sie wurden davon ausgegangen, dass sie vernetzt sind, dass sie Festplatten haben. Alle möglichen Annahmen, die halt nicht gestimmt haben. Und das zeigt halt einfach, dass der Wahlvorgang als solcher nicht verstanden wird. Bei der Chaosradio-Sendung hatten wir das noch. Anrufer von Wahlhelfern, die halt in so einem Zettelwahlbezug waren, die problemlos nach erzählen konnten, wie das da genau lief, wer wann wo wie was gemacht hat und warum sie sich total sicher sind, dass das Ergebnis, was dort ausgezählt wurde, auch gestimmt hat. Während Leute, die halt Wahlhelfer bei so einem Computer sind, ich meine, da ist man ja, was weiß ich, was ist das für ein Berufsbild? Gerätebeobachter, EDV-Bediener. Ja, EDV und ja noch nicht mal. Also die saßen ja so daneben und mussten einfach stumm hinnehmen, was ihnen die Maschine quasi angeboten hat. Und am Schluss wollte der Wahlvorstand ja noch nicht mal mit dem Ergebnis raus.
Der war eigentlich super, ja.
Also der war wirklich so nervös.
Wie war seine Formulierung?
Ihr seid nicht befugt? Also wenn der Wahlvorstand nicht befugt ist, das Ergebnis eines Wahlbezirks rauszuregen, dann ist schon echt ein bisschen was schief. Also die Stadt Cottbus wäre schon gut beraten, sich doch mal nicht nur die Pressemitteilung von dem Hersteller von Wahlgeräten durchzulesen, sondern vielleicht sich auch mal darauf zu besinnen, wofür sie nämlich eigentlich da sind, nämlich dem Bürger eine freie, geheime und sichere Wahl zu bieten. Und das war halt davon doch ganz weit entfernt. Ja, da stehen wir jetzt. Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Na ja, wie gesagt, heute Amsterdam, der erste Dominostein, SDU ist gefallen. Etwas überraschend. Also hat eigentlich niemand damit gerechnet, dass es jetzt so schnell denn doch geht.
Aber es ist ja ganz offensichtlich in Holland ein massives Thema.
Das ist ein absoluter Top-Thema. Also es ist halt überall in den Medien ganz dick. Es ist halt Standard-Thema bei der Wahlkampfberichterstattung. Was heißt das so? Immer, wenn irgendwie über den Wahlkampfbericht geht.
Was ist mit dem Irak? Was ist mit Europa? Was ist mit den Arbeitsplätzen? Und was ist mit dem Wahlcomputer?
Genau, also halt so die Statements der Kandidaten werden verlesen. Und dann wird halt irgendwie dazu nochmal die nächste Update zur Wahlcomputergeschichte gebracht. Die Frage ist halt, wann Nedap fällt. Wenn Nedap in Holland kippt, dann werden sie auch hier kippen. Es gibt jetzt Gerüchte, dass die holländischen Gemeinden sich wohl Nedaps in Deutschland borgen wollen, weil Nedap nicht so schnell neue Nedaps produzieren kann. Weil momentan ist ja nur SDU aus dem Rennen sozusagen.
Das heißt, alle Wahlcomputer Deutschlands werden ja mal kurz ins Ausland entführt und danach wieder hier.
Genau, dann müssen sie halt garantiert von der PTB auch sondergeprüft werden, weil dann waren sie in den Händen einer feindlichen Macht. Was heißt denn der Begriff? Ausländische Macht. Ausländische Macht, genau. Holland ist Eide. Ja klar, ist halt nicht Deutschland insofern. Ich denke mal, der Versuch wird da sein, zumindest irgendwie die Nedap-Dinger am Laufen zu halten. Es gibt da die wildesten Gerüchte, dass die mit Stahlbändern zugemacht sind, also der Computer-Kern sozusagen, damit da halt wirklich niemand dran kann. Noch so Geschichten. Wenn Amsterdam auf Papier wählt, dann werden sicherlich eine Menge Leute aus allen möglichen Gegenden von Holland hinfahren, um auf Papier zu wählen. Weil das Misstrauen gegen diese Wahlcomputer ist halt doch extrem groß geworden durch die breite Medienberichterstattung.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal beruhigend zu sehen, dass auch in Deutschland die Diskussion begonnen hat. Ziemlich kurz nach dem Hack wurde hier von, jemanden, den wir gar nicht kennen, eine Petition losgetreten, eine Online-Petition, die schon eine ganze Menge Unterzeichner gefunden hat. Wie viel es dann am Ende werden gegen Ende November, das wird sich zeigen. Es gibt also eine magische Zahl von 50.000. Vielleicht ist es ja auch gar nicht so magisch, wo solche Petitionen dann automatisch eine rote Lampe angehen lassen. Ob es sich dann wirklich jemand anschaut oder nicht, das steht dann noch mal auf einem ganz anderen Platz. Ich denke nicht, dass es letzten Endes davon abhängt, wie viele Leute da ihre Stimme hinterlassen, sondern ganz generell davon abhängt, dass die Diskussion in Deutschland überhaupt erst mal auf der richtigen Augenhöhe geführt wird. Nämlich, dass diese Maschinen ein grundsätzliches Problem sind und nicht, dass wir hier über Details und Sicherheitsfragen reden müssen oder was weiß ich, Videoüberwachung in Wahlkabinen einführen müssen.
Das Problem ist, in Deutschland sind die nächsten Wahlen noch lang hin. In Holland ist es am 22. November. Das heißt, es ist ein absolut akutes Thema. Mal sehen, wie sich die Lage in Deutschland entwickelt. Aber das Worst-Case-Szenario ist, dass wir das bis zu den nächsten Wahlen in Deutschland mit uns sein werden. Best-Case-Szenario ist, sie geben irgendwann auf. In Deutschland sind es nicht so viele, ich glaube, es sind unter 2000 Nedaps, die hier verkauft wurden bzw. verliest wurden. Das heißt, da sollte man schon die Möglichkeit haben, die Dinge abzuschaffen, bevor es noch schlimmer wird.
Okay, die Musik ist auch aus. Ich würde sagen, wir sind hier auch am Ende des Themas angekommen. Da schreibt die Petition, falls ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt. Ansonsten hören wir uns bald wieder beim nächsten Chaosradio Express.